hello I'm with Nia the author of hooked
how to build habit-forming products
thank you for joining us my pleasure
good to be here so tell me a little bit
about the book sure so my book is really
about how do products engage users how
do we build products and services to
keep people coming back not every
business needs to form a habit but every
business that forms a habit needs a hook
and so that's what the book is really
about it's about this pattern that I
call the hook model this four-step
process of a trigger action reward
investment that keeps people coming back
and using these various products and
services and my hope here is that we can
use the psychology of what makes
products engaging to help people live
happier healthier more productive more
connected lives by using habits for good
and now as an entrepreneur use this
model right so if you're building a
product that requires a habit so if you
think about products some of the most
successful companies over the past
several years companies like Facebook
and Google and Instagram and whatsapp
and snapchat and slack these companies
have all formed habits in users now
that's not a requirement lots of
businesses can do just fine without
forming a habit but if you're the type
of company whose business model relies
upon a habit just like those companies I
I just mentioned they would go out of
business if they had to send advertising
every time to bring people back so if
you're that kind of company if you're an
entrepreneur building a product that
requires people to come back on their
own you can use this framework to figure
out hey do I have the fundamental
elements that I need to form to build a
habit-forming product is this only for
consumer products no so if whether it's
Enterprise Products or consumer products
doesn't matter what matters is is the
product something that people use
throughout their day with little or no
conscious thought so if you're building
an enterprise application that you know
it might be some piece of software
that's put into some server farm
somewhere and nobody actually uses that
piece of software that's fine that's a
great business you know you should keep
doing that but you just don't need a
habit for that because that's not used
regularly on the other hand if you're
building an enterprise product like a
communication tool like slack or github
or Stack Overflow or Salesforce all of
these are Enterprise facing products
that necessitate habits they
why are people to come back on their own
and for those type of products you need
a hook so these hooks this four-step
process starts with a trigger to an
action and a reward and then an
investment so every hook starts with a
trigger a trigger prompts the habit and
we have these two types of triggers an
external trigger or an internal trigger
external triggers are things in our
environment that tell us what to do next
they give us some piece of information
click here by now a friend telling you
about this great new app through word of
mouth all examples of external triggers
these external triggers prompt us to
action that's the habit itself open an
app scroll through Pinterest search on
Google push the play button on YouTube
these are these actions that we do with
little or no conscious thought that are
these very simple behaviors these very
small behaviors that that we do seeking
a reward which brings me to the third
step of the hook the reward phase is
where the users itch is scratched where
they get what they came for and yet
there's a bit of mystery around what
they might find next time they engage
with the product so it's not just a
reward it turns out that habit-forming
technologies integrate what's called a
variable reward so this comes from the
classic work of BF Skinner the father of
operant conditioning
Skinner found that when he gave rewards
to his pigeons in these little boxes on
a variable basis so sometimes the
pigeons would peck at the disc they
wouldn't receive a reward the next time
they would receive a reward
what Skinner observed was that the rate
of response a number of times these
pigeons pecked at the disc increased
when the reward was given on an
intermittent schedule of reinforcement
and so in all sorts of products that we
find most habit-forming most engaging we
find this bit of mystery this bit of
variability so searching and scrolling
and scrolling on a news feed or what
makes sports fun to watch is the
uncertainty of will our team win the
game or what makes for a great TV show
or movie right the the uncertainty about
how the happy ending is going to unwind
all that these are examples of variable
rewards and finally the investment phase
the last step of the hook the investment
phase is where the user is prompted to
put something into the product to invest
in the product
in anticipation of a future benefit so
the purpose of investments is to
increase the likelihood of the next pass
that's what the investment phase is for
and it does this in two ways the
investments load the next trigger so
loading the next trigger an example that
would be when I send someone a message
on whatsapp I don't get any immediate
rewards right there's no there's no
leaderboards there's no badges there's
no points nothing really happens what
I'm doing is I'm loading the next
trigger because I'm likely to get a
reply and that reply comes coupled with
an external trigger hey here's a message
from your friend which prompts me to use
the hook once again the second way that
investments increase the likelihood of
the next pass is by storing value and
this is a big deal storing value is when
the product gets better and better with
use it appreciates in value and it does
this by storing data followers
reputation content right anything that
I'm putting into the app that gets
better and better over time and so it's
through successive cycles through these
hooks trigger action reward investment
that now an association is built with
that second type of trigger member I
told you there was two types of triggers
external triggers and internal triggers
the internal trigger is the are these
things in our life that prompt us to
action like a place a situation or
routine a certain person and most
frequently emotions that prompt us to do
this next action this next habit with
little or no conscious thought but
without any explicit information so over
time through successive cycles through
these hooks now we use the product not
with a message that tells us hey click
here but with a need with a need exactly
we internally trigger ourselves we have
these associations so I'm lonely I check
facebook I'm uncertain iGoogle I'm bored
and I'm on YouTube or reddit or checking
stock prices or sports scores right we
do these things instantaneously because
of these success successive cycles
through these hooks